she gets in the bowl
I guarantee you get some energy whip
that
oh
your Technique
get the air in there
it may get faster whip it up I'm trying
oh
is this good no it's so funny
look at the difference
Auntie's very hard on me so it's like
I'm chewing the best I can and then
she's talking all about how I'm not
mixing it right and I'm like okay how do
I mix it and then she she does it it's
like
and then I'm I'm like okay am I doing it
she's like no and then I'm just like I
just keep getting frustrated and then
number two she starts calling my arms
flabby it's like I don't need this right
now Auntie I'm trying I'm trying to
figure out she's like you wouldn't have
such flabby arms if you could just mix
the bowl and I'm just like all right
auntie I get it I get it and then she's
talking about my athleticism and I'm
just like I'm doing the best I can so I
was getting a little frustrated but I
probably I am embarrassed I did complain
more than I'm proud of I I do I did get
frustrated I'm not proud of that
that's what you need to be doing
don't take that tone up
that's what you have to do all right get
it in there whip it up with it this is
not in my day we just had a spoon at
school
do you know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
do this I'm going to show the difference
right between doing it when the Sugar's
not melted right
now stop whipping
she cracked that egg like a professional
she said
light work oh you did that right people
squeeze but they don't you don't like
crazy it's slow you're like
what's that what's that fraud
f-a-u-e-d you know that guy
the guy that everything comes back to
sex
oh Freud that's it
we grew up in the same Society
[Laughter]
now you see it's starting to separate
that means you're not beating it fast
now
okay this is what people don't
understand I okay I had a boss I used to
work at a plumbing tech company a couple
years ago and this boss said he thought
I was stupid at first
and I have this effect on people I've
noticed it multiple times where at first
they'll think I'm stupid but then I
learn really fast and I don't really
understand how my brain works or why it
works like this but it's like if I don't
understand the system I have a really
hard time like learning so if she and I
have to when I learn things it has to be
like broken down slowly and then once I
get it I can like speed it up so for
example and he's just telling me like
next you got to do it like this do it
like this if she doesn't like slowly
break down how I mix
it's like I just get frustrated and I'm
trying to think of all these things but
yeah I think in systems how I do YouTube
it's how I do everything in my life
everything has to be like a system that
connects and if I can't like connect the
dots my brain doesn't work I'm doing the
best that I can
um
do better Pearl
and where your mindset
if you whip it faster maybe you'll come
right into the door
how bad do you want a husband Whip It
[Laughter]
the men show the men
one side I'll say is this the very
little man
[Laughter]
30 second intervals like hold on ready
I'm gonna we're gonna hold on stop stop
stop stop okay yeah you got you just
started and now we're gonna do a hit
workout okay 30 seconds on 20 seconds
off 30 seconds as hard as you can whip
it 20 seconds rest okay 50 seconds just
30 seconds on 20. okay we're modern
women ready no we're athletes so this is
motivation no you can't be athletes come
on she'd have a strong arm wouldn't she
listen you haven't seen her play
volleyball
women that I know African women that can
do it better than people just don't
flicking
okay ready 30 seconds on ready on your
marks get set I do appreciate she's
giving me a timer and as an athlete we
do well on time so she is my hype woman
and I'm happy she's here today but we
gotta cool it on the laughing at the
jokes my loyalty is with pearls
um they weren't funny I was just
show them
this is my school this ain't no [__]
[__] sorry keep going disaster
15 seconds oh my God
don't laugh like five seconds go go go
go go go go go go go rest
you rest I'll take care of her she said
let me show you how you do it
you have to get all the air into it
otherwise there's something arise really
I shouldn't be making comments because
I'm just sitting here
now you can you can do the taste of her
cake afterwards yeah
when you're ready Pearl just let me know
you can jump in oh she's on okay well
it's been 20 seconds but we'll do 30
seconds on Thursdays I'll do a minute
okay go ahead Auntie
okay show how it's done
this is a this is a traditional woman
this is a traditional woman taking notes
in my head
crack that egg yeah
no shells
that's nice
it's real nice that's really nice
honestly look how velvety smooth that
thing is
here
she said boom
boom
um
that was lovely he got two next to go
okay okay 30 seconds ready
yeah set go go go go go go all right
again I think you go higher up
maybe I think you're holding it wrong
am I holding everyone I think you're
holding it a little too like that bad
yeah oh like yeah like the wrist it's on
the wrist yeah and then there you go
there you go there
you go
you got the last egg yeah
because I can't do this I've seen Pearl
lift 300 deadlift 300 and she wants to
sit here right now and complain about
mixing a cake girl bye
I not listen I have no sympathy [__] up
well I just can't my young lady okay
well I feel like that right now I've
never mixed a ball except for cookies
you don't have to do it like that okay
you know what I think might help you
think of your man crush
think of your man crush think about
you're trying to prove to him oh yeah
you're right why you're right wipe you
up you're right just picture him right
and him getting down on that one knee
my name's cyan now your food stinks yay
you've curdled the crap out of that cake
I could never marry you
okay if I mixed it enough no no
no no I gotta bring out the timer again
wait do the timer again okay all right
and work out okay round three okay round
three are you ready yeah ready yeah no
she's canceled it what what do you mean
I'm curdled you curdled it girl
it looks like vomiting
isn't that what I'm supposed to do it
the reason I want to add the flour to
stop it from curling right now you're
gonna see I'll just smooth it up for you
so it'll take a difference
it's because you're not going fast
enough
oh secret we need a bit of lemon juice
in there just so fresh
in the fridge
if you wanted something right Auntie Jen
you're gonna do it yourself
not when you're teaching someone that's
not getting a dog and barking
that's why I can't be a teacher yeah
because she's taking so long we're going
to cheat with a bit of baking powder
because in case it decides to deflate on
its own if you throw a shade
[Music]
giving up
because this is so hot
I'm a little skeptical the Cake's gonna
be good because apparently the mixing
was very bad I got a lot of negative
feedback on my mixing so I'm I'm
hesitant I hope it's good though I mean
you put sugar in anything it can be good
right heard that here first it's not
easy things
it's not easy being a housewife
because you get on me for everything
just wait till it's your man on his
shoulder at least you know that pillow
does not get special treatment
so listen right but next year I got
faith that you've been knocking it out
you've been knocking it at you I give it
like no one thing about Pearl one thing
about Pearl she catches on real fast
she's a quick learner she's a hard
worker slow at first but then once I
start to get it like it has to be I
don't know how to describe she gets the
method I learned in systems so it's like
if people try to teach me like she's
trying to teach me the recipe before I
even understand how to mix and it's like
if people teach me step three before I
know step one I get really frustrated
because I'm like I don't
I don't even understand step one
so it's like
I just learning like systems
is this good auntie yeah
it's good for you
[Music]
so we're gonna show the difference
between doing it now and doing it your
way doing it my way so how's it tastes
you
yeah it was good
can you taste the hard work and love you
put into that
yes she didn't have a cape to him that's
where they go with it
race not working
you don't want to knock any air out of
it
Auntie is this okay yeah put it in the
oven
I didn't even know I'm just saying yeah
how long do you put in the oven for
I would say about half an hour of the
top of my hair oh the women you saw her
she was you know
about to have a minute ago and you show
them what you can do she can do this
confidently on her own the oven's on do
something yeah she's an independent
woman
she doesn't need a man so kale chips
guys you put your kale on that on that
then it's pretty easy you just go put
some on and then you like mix it and
then you really just guesstimate you
know some people put more some people
across
so you make sure it gets real in there
blessing light you like my food yeah she
cooks amazing sushi
you don't cook sushi
okay it's like if you cook the salmon in
the one I mean okay I thought what Pearl
did good today was she actually got it
when I said to her is this cheaper is
that cheaper is this cheaper and once
that pointed out to her not to look at
the big price but to look at like how
much per kilo it is she got that
straight away so I was like oh which
one's the cheapest and she was looking
like I think that one's a cheapest and
she could tell me why it was the
cheapest because sometimes people think
the bigger packets are cheapest and it's
not so you always have to look at how
much you're getting per meal how much
are we getting per kilogram and the
worst thing she'd done today was Bloody
come play She complained
like a whiny child
[Music]
oh I'm tired oh it takes too much
trouble That's What She Done complain
complain complain but I will beat it out
of her wife's School
what grade would you give me so far
auntie
no I'd give her a c plus I got a set
that high honestly yeah hey but I see
Plus in England is like a bee in America
so really
that's yours yeah
smell
and give it a
smaller give us seven
all right
okay okay if you want me to be honest
when I was eating it I said it was a
seven it's kind of like when a guy asks
you what would you rate me and you're
like oh seven and he's really like a
three but you don't hurt his feelings I
would eat it would I enjoy it yeah it's
food
you know uh yeah no four I'd give it
four sorry Auntie you got it you gotta
use some salt some pepper like
the flavors are very complex
honestly I didn't get this thick by
eating air sandwiches
I'm not gonna lie I'm not gonna lie I
think it's a little under seasoned
under season a little really yeah
with the curry no it's not I don't cook
with sauce
I would say add your own salt in my
house apparently I just saw it
all right all right by the salt now okay
next go about I don't cook with salt
that's why now it is
what does she say I love that [__]
all right I will give it a 7.5 out of
10. thank you
y'all passed past wife's wife school
today
um I feel like they're being nice
um actually I think antsy made the curry
I gave the curry a six I meant to five
I'm sorry Auntie I'm sorry I'm sorry I
don't want to give you five I think
everyone would have given it a five but
it's like I'm from America
um America and we we like the fat we
like the salt and it's just gonna be
okay if you don't have that in it the
asparagus needs some sort of seasoning I
think
that's it I usually do my asparagus with
like some garlic and lemon
I'm gonna do mine in the microwave in
there get some bacon some streaky bacon
and lay it out I'll put some hot mustard
on it and then roll it around I mean I
made it with you
I spent a lot more time on the cake the
chicken was yours from yesterday anyway
so yeah six I got red peppers
I'd give it a five five yeah yeah it's
about five
all right next time do an Italian food
you're gonna do Italian food okay I
could do that because I love Italian
food the cake was bomb okay I don't care
what anyone says that cake was bomb I
mixed it the perfect amount she's trying
to [__] on my mix it sorry shoot on my
mixing I don't swear now and
and you know
it was bomb it was good the cake they
put their foot in that cake
I give the cake like a seven remark
number one I don't understand why we
can't use this that's remark known for
what again sometimes the older
generation wants to do things the hard
way just to do it the hard way to build
character
um but I I do have a lot of respect
for you know I thought I could cook
because I can cook more than most modern
women however the longer that I see
women that can really cook I realize I
can't cook so I realized I have a long
ways to go but I am excited that I've
started learning and I've started on my
journey and I'm excited to learn more
and I have a long ways to go but I'm
excited that's it why School Mains
getting the women to be
[Music]
thank you
put your own salt in the food right
respect hell yeah I'm putting my own
salt in that bland ass [__] it was
better 4.5 after the salt best I can
give it I've got a lot to say when I'm
not here about my food than what I am or
I have school I'm Gonna Make Them Suffer
you know
well they're gonna suffer
[Music]
foreign